All right, so
that's hierarchical Lucas-Kanade.
And as we described it,
it gives you a dense flow feel,
it gives you a u,v in every location.
But remember we said that we might
only want to do Lucas-Kanade
at areas where the eigenvalues
were well behaved,
that is the places that
were kind of corner like.
So, there's a version of Lucas-Kanade
called Sparse Lucas-Kanade
which is just that.
It's a hierarchical version of,
that's applied only to what they call
good locations or
good features to track.
This actually comes out of some
work by Shi and Tomassian,
good features to track and
applying Lucas–Kanade to it.
And by the way,
those of you who use openCV,
the Lucas–Kanade used to be dense and
then they just changed it.
It's now actually sparse so
now it only gives it to you
at a select set of points.
And they sort of changed it without
telling you because the function still
compiles, it just,
your code just breaks a little.
So so you should only be using the,
the sparse version.